first of all you don't need college
learning learn stuff
okay everything is available basically
for free
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be
or anything you ever used to do if you
don't love your work
you're never gonna be great at it wanna
be happy
live a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how billionaires
think to get some success advice from
the top
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn on your own with elon musk
first of all you don't need college
learning learn stuff
okay everything is available basically
for free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
there there is a value that colleges
have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's is
can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of sort of annoying
homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh
and and kind of soldier through and and
get it done
you know that's that's like the main
value of college and then also you know
if you you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning rule number
two don't hold yourself hostage with
oprah winfrey
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be
or anything you ever used to do because
who has lived and hasn't made mistakes
when i think about my 20s and what a
foolish girl i was
and how i would give over my power
to men who really didn't mean me well
but now i hold no grudges against them
either because i realize
i'm the one who gave over the power
because i didn't know any better
and now that i know better i know i
don't have to do that again
it's one of the most powerful lessons
any of us can ever know rule number
three choose to do hard things with jeff
bezos
a young person starting their career
i think there are probably a lot of
things some of them are very well known
and people have heard them many times
they're still true
one of those is you should always focus
on a young person should
find something that they're passionate
about to do
and that's not going to surprise anyone
it's it's a clear thing to do it's very
hard if you don't love your work
you're never going to be great at it
i think the other thing i would suggest
to any young person even before they
start their career
is to really think about their choices
because i find young people and i
i when i was young i had i made this
mistake too
you can get very fixed on your
gifts so everybody has gifts you know
you you have gifts and you have things
that you didn't get gifted maybe you're
extremely beautiful maybe you're
extremely good at mathematics maybe you
there are a lot of things that you can
be given but those things can confuse
you
because they're not the things that
construct your life it's your choices
that construct your life
not your gifts you can celebrate your
gifts be proud of them be happy of them
actually don't be proud of them be be
celebratory of them because you can't be
proud because they're gifts they were
given to you you didn't earn them
you can only be proud of the things you
earn and so
as i got older i started to realize i
wasn't proud of my
gifts i was always good at school school
was always easy for me
and i was always proud that i was a
great student i got a's in all my
classes
i was good at math all of that and i
thought
i thought that's who i was but it's not
true
those are the things that are gifts what
was hard for me is deciding to work hard
deciding to use my gifts in certain ways
to challenge myself to do things that i
didn't think i could do to put myself in
uncomfortable situations
we all get i would say to a young person
you can choose a life
of ease and comfort or you can choose a
life
of service and adventure which one of
those when you're 90 years old
are you going to be more proud of also
if you want to have unstoppable
confident self-love and learn from
billionaires check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
for me i've seen small things get big
and it's part of this day one mentality
i like treating things as if if they're
small but if you ask me to write a story
on what is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out and
so you get rule number four make it
happen with bill gates
the idea that computers were going to be
a change agent
and i was lucky enough to meet paul
allen
and early on we brainstormed about this
i did the ship
and the chip changed the rules i mean
most things don't get a million times
better
not you know engine efficiency or
uh you know most things have uh
theoretical minimums
computation is something that uh we're
not even close to the theoretical
minimum and yet
we've improved so much so seeing that
that was going to come
and weirdly that most people didn't see
that was going to come so
you know even people at ibm were still
thinking in terms of big computers
you know now all the the uh software and
service driven companies are worth even
more than ibm
when i was growing up ibm was the
monolith and it was always okay
are we going to beat them are we going
to join them those bastards
actually they were very nice people but
we always thought of them
and they they sort of stood for these
big computers that only big companies
and governments could get
the benefit for so actually we played
off of that to have this
power to the people personal computing
type thing of course now we're a big
company
and somebody can play off of us the idea
that a young person can start a company
here
is a super nice thing because although
people at first are skeptical
as soon as they realized their normal
model of what i knew and what i could do
that i didn't fit that normal
model then they assumed i knew way more
than i did and i could solve all sorts
of problems i had no clue
uh you know how to solve but you know it
was nice
uh that people were kind of a gog that
we had built this company and done these
things
from a young age so i think the culture
of america that you know
almost the american dream type success
story uh
worked out rule number five love what
you do with warren buffett
in my own case i was sort of wired for
capital allocation
and being wired for capital allocation a
couple hundred years ago
in nebraska wouldn't have been a thing
uh and
and even now being born in various parts
of the world it wouldn't have been much
but here i was in this
soon-to-be very rich capitalistic system
and and
it just so happened to what i did paid
off enormously in a market system like
we have and i
if i'd had a talent in some other area
that was
way less commercial i mean i would have
i would have had a good time doing it
but it wouldn't have paid off like this
but of course jay said it perfectly when
he talked about
you know he's in the recording for
himself and the money comes afterwards i
mean i
i got to do what i love i mean and it
doesn't get any luckier than that if
if you can spend your life time and i'm
80 now and doing things you love every
single day i mean
i would be doing what i did what i do
now and i would have done in the past
if the payoff had been in seashells or
sharks teeth or anything else
that it if you can go to work every
morning i tap dance to work you know and
i come down and i
every day is exciting rule number six
learn to communicate with mark
zuckerberg
recently you shared in a press
conference
that one of facebook's focuses for the
next decade
is that it is more important to be
understood
than be liked will you just share what
you meant by that
yeah i mean
look it's let's be real here i'm not i'm
not like
communicating is not my best thing right
um
you know i came out here i've been
planning for this i'm excited about it
and then i messed up the name of our
data center within 30 seconds
so i mean look when when i got started
with facebook i was 19.
and um and there were so many parts
about building a company that i didn't
know right
i didn't i didn't know anything about
hiring or managing or building a company
and i certainly didn't
really know that much about you know how
to
communicate about what we were doing
with the world i'm an engineer by
training right i
i love coding i like building products
that's that's kind of the background
um and uh you know my experience
you know kind of growing up and running
the company is you know it went out
talked about what we did
say some stupid things get called out
for it and get like
kind of go into a in into a shell right
and and
uh end up being really cautious about
how we
communicate so you know it kind of it
worked out okay
for a while for the company because
we we built products that a lot of
people really like and you know we
weren't winning because we were
communicating well we were winning
because the products were working well
i think in spite of the fact that we
were communicating quite poorly about
what we were doing but
broadly speaking for a long time uh the
basic approach was okay
let's try to not like do anything that's
gonna be too offensive
right and and we'll kind of explain what
we're doing in broad strokes and
talk about the mission of what we're
doing which is something that i really
believe in helping to
build community and and bring people
closer together
but you know i think we just shied away
for a long time talking about some of
the things that
some of the principles that we believe
in that that um that are increasingly
controversial in the world
and i just think that we for one don't
have that luxury anymore
for two uh i i think that that kind of
led for a while to a sentiment towards
the company that was
positive but fairly shallow because if
people if if you're not
kind of out there standing for things
that uh that people care about then
you know it's not possible for people to
feel that strongly about what you're
doing but
so now you know i i've just i've tried
to change our approach more recently
you know i went out and i in georgetown
last year i gave this
speech around our principles around free
expression
and you know that's just one of the
areas that i really feel like is under
attack right now
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is prepare for the long run with jack ma
and also i encourage an old
entrepreneurs
if you want to start a business don't
think you will be successful next month
or next year think about at least the
five years
because if something can be successful
next month
why you you have a rich father you don't
have to be startup
right and by the way don't be
discouraged because you have a poor
diploma
or you know graduate from a poor
university
or low education don't worry about that
if you graduate from
mit harvard you would never be
entrepreneur
right they can only be the white collar
guys
so as an entrepreneur you should have
this what is the strategy for
entrepreneurs
strategy is time 10 years you compete
with the other people
the vision the world will be there will
be there
what kind of customers they need how we
can build it up if you
prepare for five years and 10 years if
you have a good team
and always do before the government do
if you're waiting for government you
have no chance
right when governments say there is
opportunity there go that direction
because it would be too crowded there
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take
action on it this week let me know put
it down in the comments below
the first question you're going to get
asked when you go to apply for a job
whether it's now or some point in the
future
is what did you learn what did you do
what skills did you add during the
pandemic of 2020
and i think it's imperative to anybody
looking to
to get a job to really push themselves
forward
to do better than their parents to
really place a focus on learning
you know i i think you'd agree mike and
anybody watching that one of the
greatest skills that we all can have
in the in the business world is a thirst
for knowledge just being excited about
learning and knowing how to learn
and this really is the best opportunity
ever
for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a coursera
class or you know in the past i would
have said reading a lot of books but now
having
learned from my kids going on youtube
and you know
watching tutorials and watching videos
on various
subjects you know i learned how to write
a three letter
three layer javascript neural network on
youtube and so
there's a unique opportunity now for you
to add skills
particularly in areas like artificial
intelligence
that are going to be in great demand
that most people have not yet learned
because
you know it's it's so recent that it's
become really applicable
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want another video to see how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there